so yesterday I told you that it's
important to remember that the Trump
policy of separating the migrant
children from their parents isn't a
policy that Trump came up with on his
own right it did happen under the Obama
administration and the right is very
very quick to say that what's important
to remember is that even though the
policy wasn't sort of invented by Trump
it's being scaled up in significant
numbers under Donald Trump not only as
applied to people who are crossing the
border illegally but also to individuals
who are at the border requesting
political asylum the Trump
administration is also scaling up the
number of children that are going to be
held in these internment style camps
some of them in hundred degree weather
and I've told you about the project in
Fort Bliss Texas where it's been over a
hundred degrees most days this week to
create a de-facto internment camp and
it's true that it's not Trump's policy
from a sort of out of thin air but
Donald Trump is scaling it up and he's
doing it in an even more immoral way
than what was happening before we now
have for our consideration a
whistleblower who quit working at one of
these child detention centers in Tucson
Arizona where he says he was forced by
his employer to tell sibling children
who had been separated from their
parents not to hug this is an interview
from yesterday's episode of democracy
now check this out antar davidson quit
after he says southwest key forced him
to tell children who were separated from
their mother and from their siblings not
to hug and her davidson welcome to
Democracy Now can you talk about why you
quit your job last week sure definitely
thank you first and foremost Amy for
having me on the show I just want to
clarify a little bit the timeline of
events that first night when they told
me not to hug that prompted me to seek
change internally I reached out to a
Regional Director then later in the
interview he gets more into the
specifics of this hugging stuff which is
just vile deplorable unimaginable
kids the oldest brother was six the
oldest brother was sixteen the sister
was ten and the younger brother was
eight so at that moment the shift leader
ran up to me and very aggressively told
me the less cannot wait another sod tell
them that they can't hug now this is
also in front of other children other
employees who are watching this and so
she screams at me to tell them not to
hug that they're not allowed to hug
that's the rule of Southwest key and
meanwhile I'm looking at these kids it's
the two little the two little siblings
just you know thinking they're gonna be
ripped now from their brothers arms and
the brother crying because he can't do
anything necessarily and I told her at
that point when she she told me to do
that I told her I'm sorry but as a human
being that's not something that I could
do you're welcome to do it yourself to
which she replied first that she would
report me to the supervisor and then she
went directly to them and said and no
way they're not gonna sign it you're not
allowed to hug and he looks at me with
tears streaming down his face in utter
disbelief that that would happen
antar davidson subsequently quit
Southwest key so there's multiple major
issues here to discuss and I am unsure
sort of where to start but I'll start in
one place let's talk about the policy
first right the escalation of the policy
to separate kids from parents is immoral
and vile and pointing to this also being
legal under Obama doesn't excuse in any
way the deliberate effort to ramp this
up by the Trump administration that's
number one it's what about ISM to say
this was also legal under Obama secondly
Southwest key is the company in question
here right Southwest West Key is a
nonprofit that runs these types of they
call them programs you might call them
detention centers call them whatever you
want in different parts of the country
and the government contracts with them
and the fact that this is such a
successful endeavor in the u.s. is
horrible I'm calling it an endeavor
because Southwest key isn't a for-profit
company so to call it a profitable thing
is it would be technically wrong but
it's a very successful endeavor to run
these programs and to have the
government subcontract out to you child
internment camps right in
the United States of America in 2018
exist and they're being run not by the
government directly but it has been
outsourced and subcontracted to major
organizations and then number three that
I think is important to mention here is
the fact that anybody at any level of
government that seeks out places to
stick kids separated from their parents
in a hundred degree weather like Fort
Bliss which I've mentioned is absolutely
shameful and disgusting and what we're
very quickly heading towards is what's
called corporate state ISM since Donald
Trump was elected president of the
United States and was inaugurated more
importantly the term fascism has been
thrown around a lot the move towards
fascism and there's no one way to define
fascism exactly but it's typically
authoritarian which we do have under
Trump it's typically nationalistic which
we also have under Trump it involves
usually dictatorial power which Trump
would like to have we don't actually
have it right now but certainly that
something Trump would like it involves
suppression of opposition certainly
something we have attempt at but it's
not really fascistic at this point in
time and you also have government
control of industry and commerce we
don't we don't really have that right
now what I believe that we have is a
form of corporate statism corporate
statism is where you have a sort of
different phenomena or relationship
between the United States between the
United States government and
corporations and it's you can sort of
think about it as government Inc or in
other words the state becomes the
corporate group which underlies society
right interest groups get major status
and power we have that in the United
States government will delegate to
corporations activities which should
really be government roles private
prisons are an example of that child
detention centers are another example of
that whether it's for-profit or
nonprofit is not hugely relevant here
and to get back to the specifics of this
particular case antar Davidson
the right thing as an individual for him
right he quit because what is happening
at these detention centers with this
sort of outsourcing of what would
presumably be government tasks to in
organizations or corporations he felt
was wrong
the internment camps that we are going
to have soon immoral and unethical the
problem is that antar Davidson is going
to be replaced by somebody who's not
gonna feel compelled to quit and I said
last week we need hundreds of social
workers at these camps and when good
people quit because they won't tolerate
the vile nature of what's going on he's
going to get replaced with somebody
who's not so good that's just a reality
that's not a criticism of antar Davidson
right I understand why he did what he
did but the solution isn't people like
him quitting because they'll be replaced
by people who don't have as much of a
problem with it or any problem at all
and what a grotesque
policy - I mean what's the negative
externality of allowing these kids to
hug one another why would they have a
policy against I would guess that it's
because if you allow kids to hug but you
want to prevent I don't know I like
inappropriate contact if you allow any
contact you now need to have people like
antar Davidson adjudicating what's okay
what is it so the siblings it doesn't
make any sense though I guess they just
say no contact and then that way they
don't have to figure that out folks this
is totally not a child prison camp no
way it is fake news punch me in the face
Pat please off air but now you put kids
in cages you can no longer claim the
moral high ground for your actions and
you can no longer claim that the rule of
law is your sort of guiding principle